[Music]
good morning John it's Monday December
3rd
welcome to December here's my guitar
I've been playing my new song
[Music]
this is a misprint in business card now
I just have them sitting all over my
house because I still haven't figured
out what to do with them
I thought through what I would have
talked about because there's news we
just got our 10,000 subscriber actually
we just got our 10,000 20-second
subscriber I just went to try and find
our 10,000 subscriber 10,000 subscriber
that is not easy to say
and that person is TG I 86 he's just a
21 year old guy with nothing but
skydiving on his mind
mmm nerd fighter so if anybody wants to
go to his MySpace and say thank you it's
at myspace comm slash TGI 86 if you
think I wouldn't just found some really
hilarious fashion shots from MySpace no
that is actually a 10,000 subscriber
Thank You TGI 86 and thank you to
everyone all 10,000 of you who
subscribed to Brotherhood 2.0 videos I
don't know what we're going to do to
thank you except um I have to ask a
favor
since there are 10,000 and 22 I'm kind
of hoping that like the 22 of you can
unsubscribe kind of bug in me so just 22
of you on subscribe and then I'll have
an even 10,000 and I will feel much
better that would be great if you could
do that please no no no not really
actually what would be better is if nine
thousand nine hundred and eighty-eight
of you 78 could subscribe and then it
would be an even 20,000 either 22 of you
unsubscribe or nine thousand nine
hundred and eighty-eight 78 have you
subscribed
obligatory Center screenshot it's party
blower solo fan art from Ally okay okay
okay okay okay I actually have a real
favor to ask a few people I told you
last week about the old time host of a
nerdfighter project ever I have realized
that this is going to have to be a
secret project so I'm sorry about that I
can't tell you out in the open like this
because people who are not participating
in the project shouldn't be allowed to
know about it yet because it has to be a
surprise so in order for you to find out
what it is you have to go to Brotherhood
do.com right now or click on the link in
the sidebar and sign up for the secret
project email list we promised not to
use your information for anything except
Brotherhood 2.0 and nerdfighting
purposes we will not share your
information with anyone we promise
brother
if they put an ad in the sidebar it's
probably down there brother you got come
go now shut up okay if you're on brother
go to calm all of this gesturing
probably didn't make very much sense
however in order to participate in the
secret project you will have to have a
youtube account I'm sorry about that for
you non youtubers know that there are
plenty of you but the secret project is
somewhat YouTube centric seriously I do
feel bad about that because we started
with the very non YouTube centric
audience and now we have more of a
YouTube centric audience but I do
promise that not only will it be
extremely awesome and on YouTube but it
will also be an effort to decrease
worldsuck a combined effort of lots of
nerdfighters to decrease worldsuck
in a really awesome way so if you want
to sign up for youtube this is a good
time to do it
and if not and if there's a lot of non
youtube nerdfighters who want to get
involved we will definitely be able to
find a way to get you involved don't
worry
today's scavenger hunt clue is online
only and it has something to do with the
secret bucket